hello welcome to this video chromis yeah
I think isn't just a guy who placed them
doesn't he play the how it's called the
Chi going she going all the time
probably ogle knight c6 now yeah that's
a chicken guy let's see you maybe this
is not a bad move war against the
children trying to trying to avoid a pin
with Bishop g4 if I go see for now he
might have some funky ideas like Bishop
be one look be one if I for Bishop
before check or maybe night before even
by the night ain't no not before I have
the check I'm sorry that's not going to
work see phone but but the c5 business
retains me but should be one would be
one you five and i know it also cost
some time let's go for that it's
somewhat risky no I really shouldn't
should do those calculations they never
play this stuff it was interesting but
should be 185 totally also in spirit of
the of the chi or in defense now I just
have a good position for nothing
basically just a bad kind of Queens
gambit okay um queen bee three or how
yeah let's do it be three simple simple
chess he has to go Bishop before I guess
okay maybe will be eight maybe
Bishop before also kind of normal for
this for this kind of positions no not
really guessing any move here right why
isn't this good for white just simple
with simple moves strange check and the
night only 5 is just in a weird spot
and the question is here something like
I'd be five I can even sacrifice I can
just take plane I'd be five and win so
I'm threatening before that's the
problem trapping the night and it
doesn't really i mean if he goes be 5
i'll play 95 and that's it CBP are not
be five why isn't that winning I don't
don't quite check see addy fancy king is
seven queen before as an immediate made
into mousse and 97 5727 Queen f5 also
it's just just over I can also go Knight
f3 here is that was that unusual
unnecessary fanciness rook see one looks
7s also interesting but it's just a good
move right threatening 95 there's really
no way out of the day I can take that
it's a benefit of the bishop on f4 black
resides Jim that was a very weird
opening play web like yeah I think hear
what I wanted this is he he should
consider it just read this and I think
this is an interesting tribe rupee
wanted if I've that it was well this was
when I was thinking about for a bit
because he now gets in this check and I
don't have I have to move the King which
is not not that great ok this is given
by the comp maybe it's good
it doesn't feel super clear the engine
gives this funny line check preparing
Bishop c4 and now root g five per mcf
over 55 with a slight advantage for
white yeah damn I think I agree white
hasn't has a center poor near
controlling useful squares and i'm a bit
quicker here with my development even
though the king is funky on a three yeah
it didn't do that at TM i think this
should be just a bit better for wide
queen bee three NT a bishop before as
normal maybe you can also go here group
b eight no i'm not quite short of what I
would have done no I even thought about
the c5 briefly going for Bishop b5 next
but night h5 looks decent I don't have a
good square I would like to preserve
that bishop but you have to go Bishop d3
down okay took surprisingly check and
now we're back so what is the move oh
the computer finds a good one a move
that I didn't take into account at all
Queen to be six going to be six aha know
that that I didn't think about yeah it
makes quite some sense it prevents
before and it actually attacks be too
and currently I really don't have a
great way to cover it i probably have to
go here now that's not ideal this is the
line given by the computer and blackest
black is better
yeah like it's okay yeah definitely
Queen B 6 aha but then this is probably
a case where it really has to do this
but because before is a very substantial
threat and what he did of course doesn't
work at all yeah that then just loses
Chinese straight away and neither three
is a bit more precise than taking check
I could have taken and taken here for
two points but there is no reason not to
play neither three first because black
is now facing this thread and you don't
really have a good move there the engine
wants to go f6 and now can I can get
this back and have a clear advantage
with the two pods like really has no
compensation for that yeah so we could
have played Queen B 6 that's interesting
it's a move that I did not think about
ready yeah I was just thinking that this
is cannot possibly be good yeah put the
night on a 5 with a pollen c6 and so on
but it is some is good for concrete
reason cm it's just that I cannot
conveniently cover that pawn yeah and
long castles Bishop before it's okay if
you like em interesting okay thanks for
watching